while more people are shopping online of
course so that means more deliveries
law enforcement officers want you to
watch out for porch pirates
bianca holman shows us how you can
protect your holiday gifts from thieves
how the grinch stole christmas might be
your favorite holiday movie but it can
become a reality for some
that's because thieves are looking to
steal packages right from your doorstep
what people need to do is target harden
their own
residence or their own place of business
and you know advise your neighbor if
you're not going to be around or you
expect to receive a package or if you
have a security guard through an hoa
advise them and help maybe they can help
you some criminals are so bold
they follow delivery trucks quietly
waiting nearby for the chance to steal
packages
you have the option to inform the
delivery driver where to leave your
boxes
maybe over a fence or behind a large
plant
one major step you can take to protect
your packages is having a doorbell
camera or some type of security system
you can register your camera with metro
have their video cameras working
that's a definite assist for the police
department do an investigation
and it's important for people to be
aware of their surroundings so
don't make it easy for the crooks the
sheriff also says don't post on social
media
sharing the fact that you'll be out of
town that could make you a target
reporting bianca holman 8 news now